so Tim it's wonderful having you here
and we're all appreciative of your role
as one of the chief organizers of the
program on economics and computer
science
what what led you and others in
theoretical computer science to begin
thinking about economics great
so I'm also happy to be here so it's
been a lot of fun so far with this
semester on economics and computation
second Damas and computation that it
really emerged is a field maybe about 15
years ago around the turn of the century
it's also called algorithmic game theory
sometimes and the milieu at that point
so you know some of you many viewers
will call that the internet was just
becoming really commercially widespread
at that point in the late 90s computer
science broadly including theory
recognized that there gonna be these new
applications coming down the pipe which
needed new science and so in particular
you had a lot of cases where you know
traditionally in the 80s we would think
of a computer is just having a single
user and just being a standalone machine
whereas now of course you had many
machines connected to each other with
the different end users perhaps having
very different goals from each other and
different goals from the designer so you
know you talk about interaction between
self-interested age agents entities and
you naturally think about game theory
and its tools of equilibria and how to
reason about them so I know that one of
the famous results in the field is the
computational difficulty of computing
and nash equilibrium is that a cause for
concern
that's a good question yeah so about 10
years ago there's some some just amazing
results from das Calaca school but
Papadimitriou and then also chen deng
and ten which formalized through a
definition called peabody completeness
formalized the belief that there's no
computationally efficient algorithm for
computing a Nash equilibrium even just
in a two-player non zero sum game so the
questions about interpretation and you
know different people will give you
different answers about this but
I would say it adds to an ongoing list
of critiques over the Nash equilibrium
concept now ever since the concept was
defined you know about 65 years ago it
was known that it had flaws in
particular Nash equilibria need not be
unique so if you want to interpret a
Nash equilibrium as a prediction of many
yes and the question is which do you
choose and so there's a big cottage
industry of equilibrium selection to
deal with that but it's not really a
consensus about the right way to resolve
the problem so it's it's not an it's not
a new idea to say that Nash equilibria
aren't perfect to have issues with
prediction but really I think the
computational critique first of all I
think it's important you know I think
ever since herb Simon you know people
talk about boundedly rational players
and what implications would that have
also I just think theoretical peer
science is uniquely well-positioned to
make formal the idea that there might be
computational difficulty is behind the
equilibrium concept and indeed the
definition of pped it's quite subtle
it's really kind of you know impressive
complexity theory the reductions showing
the completeness results are very
impressive reductions and so you know I
think our community is sort of justly
proud of those results I think it's a
big contribution more and more over time
we've found here at the Simons Institute
that the participants in the program the
long-term visitors and the postdoctoral
fellows form a coherent social community
which makes things much more enjoyable
and probably contributes to their
ability to collaborate and be productive
is that happening in the economics
program I think it is yeah so when we
had our first organizational meeting
during our bootcamp I was speaking to
the group I said a little bit
tongue-in-cheek but I sort of meant it I
said you know as the organizers we
thought our job was to get a bunch of
great people to show up and we were
ready to declare victory and at that
time for the participants to take
ownership of the program and that's
happened to a degree that has just been
absolutely terrific so the participants
said they're running two different
seminar series that run every week
there's no less than six reading groups
that were established and and the
attendance at all of these events were
just kind of amazing
other participants have led the charge
of having field trips to both down to
Stanford and also to some Bay Area
companies like like Google and Facebook
so really this just been a lot of energy
it's been really amazing